el derrumbre de la represa de desechos
mineros en brumadinho cubrió un
equivalente a 300 campos de fútbol con
lodo tóxico y mató a 270 personas dos
años después el propietario de la presa
el gigante minero vale anunció que
pagaría cinco mil setecientos millones
de euros por daños al estado de minas
gerais
vale se compromete a reparar y compensar
íntegramente los daños causados por la
tragedia de broma dinho y a contribuir
cada vez más a la mejora y desarrollo de
las comunidades en las que operamos
confiamos en que este acuerdo global sea
un paso importante en esta dirección
el gobierno estatal solicitó
originalmente 8 mil 400 millones de
euros y dijo que la cantidad acordada
era sólo una estimación inicial el
acuerdo está destinado a cubrir los
daños socioeconómicos y medioambientales
al estado e incluye unos 1.400 millones
de euros en indemnizaciones directas a
las víctimas sin embargo las familias de
los afectados rechazaron el acuerdo y
prometieron demandar por una cantidad
mayor ahora las casas están abandonadas
en brut mariño y los lugareños aseguran
que la ciudad todavía necesita ayuda
desesperadamente está curve al apra ming
no me importa el acuerdo quiero que me
compensen por mi propiedad porque esto
ya no es un lugar para vivir ni cobre
que permita que para mí que la lugar ama
es que haya un poco y les pedimos que
vivir en el lugar ya hemos sufrido mucho
por esta tragedia aquí junto con esta
tragedia que el acuerdo no cubre los
cargos penales relacionados con el
desastre los fiscales han acusado a 16
personas incluido el ex presidente de
vale de homicidio intencional y delitos
medioambientales alegando que ocultaban
el riesgo de colapso que tenía la presa
aunque en el pasado ya se vivieron otras
roturas de presas en las que se acusó al
sector minero esta será la primera en
contar con una indemnización importante
en brasil